da wo haiti anfängt liegt sieht es ein
riesiger flop armut und elend dafür
steht haiti mehr als die hälfte der
haitianer ist unter 25
was heißt es denn in so einem land jung
zu sein welche perspektiven hat man gibt
es möglichkeiten auszubrechen aus dem
elend etwa 400.000 menschen leben in
cité soleil in hütten ohne fließend
wasser ohne kanalisation mit weniger als
zwei dollar pro tag
blexen sind vom leben im ghetto von
armut und gewalt sagt fed was geht heißt
seine botschaft leute liegt die waffen
weg lasst uns in frieden leben in cité
soleil herrschen die gags und die sind
gerade wieder einmal im krieg während
wir filmen hören wir immer wieder
schüsse
wir können hier nur drehen weil unser
haitianischer kollege sersch bei uns ist
er kennt sich aus und weiß wo sich heißt
im bandenkrieg geht es um kontrolle von
gebieten skrupellose politiker schüren
die unruhen zusätzlich wo armut und
hunger herrschen und das leben
schrecklich ist gibt es immer wieder
konflikte und politiker nutzen das aus
sie bringen uns in eine situation wo wir
immer pleite sind und nicht genug geld
haben um unsere kinder zur schule zu
schicken und dann sind wir leichte beute
sie verteilen ein bisschen geld und
benutzen uns für ihre eigenen zwecke zb
bei den massenprotesten im vergangenen
jahr einige in cité soleil erzählen uns
dass sie geld bekamen um auf der straße
krawall zu machen gewalt angeheizt von
oppositionspolitikern die den
präsidenten absetzen wollten dutzende
menschen kamen dabei ums leben
das land war monatelang lahmgelegt dabei
hatten die proteste durchaus legitime
ursprünge benzinknappheit inflation
steigende preise das fass lief über als
bekannt wurde dass die regierung über
zwei milliarden dollar veruntreut hatte
das geld war von venezuela als hilfe für
das haitianische volk gedacht
erst machten die menschen ihrem ärger in
den sozialen medien luft dann gingen sie
zu tausenden auf die straße emanuela war
mittendrin
die proteste waren für sie nur der
anfang sie will für nachhaltige
veränderung kämpfen und hat sich mit
gleichgesinnten zusammen geschlossen wir
sind keine politiker die den präsidenten
stürzen wollen um selbst an die macht zu
kommen
wir sind eine bewegung der
zivilgesellschaft uns geht es um
grundlegende reformen
wir wollen leute die qualifiziert und
nicht korrupt sind
wir wollen das wahlsystem ändern
das rechtssystem einfach alles
wir sagen das was wir bisher hatten
funktioniert nicht mehr zeit für was
neues
sie wollen das ohne gewalt erreichen
bisher haben wir traditionelle methoden
von interessensgruppen benutzt um druck
auf die regierung auszuüben sit-ins
demonstrationen unterschriftenaktionen
aber je länger wir das machen desto mehr
wird uns klar es ist schwierig jemanden
unter druck zu setzen dem sein volk egal
ist manuela nimmt uns mit zum
strategietreffen sie haben ihre gruppe a
promi getauft das ist kreolisch für wir
schlafen nicht wie sehen eure korruption
wollen sie den politikern damit sagen
wir werden nicht unsere augen davor
verschließen
sie sind aus der mittelschicht gehören
nicht zu reichen elite trotzdem auch sie
sind privilegiert die meisten haben im
ausland studiert viele in ihrer
situation würden das land verlassen
doch immer nur ja und die anderen haben
sich bewusst für ein leben in haiti
entschieden sie wollen mithelfen hier
etwas aufzubauen
wenn du nicht tust ändert sich auch
nichts es wird nicht einfach jemand mit
einem zauberstab aus dem nichts kommen
und veränderung herbei zaubern das
quatsch wir müssen unsere realität schon
selbst ändern
wir müssen gegen dass das team an
kämpfen es hängt von uns selbst ab
sie glauben dass es möglich ist
auszubrechen aus dem teufelskreis wo
korrupte eliten einander die macht zu
schustern während die hälfte der
haitianer ums nackte überleben kämpft
aber sie können es nicht alleine
schaffen sie brauchen die unterstützung
der bevölkerung
wir sagen den leuten das ist eure
einzige chance
was bleibt euch schon übrig wenn du in
haiti lebt bist du entweder korrupt und
klaus sowie politiker oder du
verzweifelt und willst dich umbringen
oder du kämpfst also was machst du
versteckst du die arme und wartest auf
den tod oder schließt du dich dem kampf
die botschaft kommt an
so unterschiedlich ihre lebensumstände
auch sind domin und blexen sind dabei
ihn unterstütze die bewegung von ganzem
herzen denn es ist eine bewegung für uns
junge für gerechtigkeit
die gesellschaft unterstützt das auch
denn es ist gut für uns es wird zeit
dass wir haitianer unser schicksal
selbst in die hand nehmen
wir brauchen eine nationale bewegung
gegen die leute die haiti schaden
lasst uns alle zusammen kommen und dass
haiti unserer träume bauruine ruby
jacobi ist da schon ganz konkret dran
sein traum ist ein gemeindezentrum
mitten in cité soleil wenn das gebäude
fertig ist soll es hier eine bücherei
geben
ein sprachlabor einen computerraum für
fernkurse die bewohner sollen einen
sicheren zufluchtsort haben und
möglichkeiten sich weiterzubilden
wir bauen wir etwas konkretes
wir wollen den menschen in cité soleil
zeigen dass ein besseres leben eine
andere zukunft möglich ist und dass es
dabei nicht nur um geld geht geld allein
kann unsere situation nicht verändern
wir haben solidarität und liebe
warum nutzen wir das nicht unser
schicksal zu verbessern
dieses projektes ein zeichen dafür dass
wir es gemeinsam schaffen können
und wenn es in cité soleil klappt und
ist es überall möglich
es fühlt sich eigenartig an ringsum
bekriegen sich die gangs und er spricht
von liebe und solidarität wie soll das
funktionieren
es geht nur wenn alle mitziehen deshalb
sammelt ruby überall in cité soleil geld
für das projekt über 6.000 spender hat
er schon viele von ihnen sind arme
slumbewohner die nur ein paar cent
beitragen können
jeder block hat geld investiert dadurch
ist das projekt geworden
und obwohl die sich bekriegen sagen sie
finger weg vom gemeindezentrum das ist
ein riesen zeichen die leute beschützen
etwas an dem sie beteiligt sind also
wenn du soleil ändern willst beteilige
alle initiativen wie die von ruby und
luka kumi bringen hoffnung auf
veränderungen und die ist dringend nötig
gerade junge haitianer leiden oft unter
perspektivlosigkeit es ist schwer fuß zu
fassen in einem land wo zwei drittel der
bevölkerung keine richtige arbeit haben
paul kempf noch in seinem kleinen laden
setzt die weihnachtsdekoration staub an
es gibt keine kunden das kunsthandwerk
aus blech hat in haiti tradition paul
wollte sich damit eine ausbildung als
buchhalter finanzieren
eine weile lief das geschäft nach dem
großen erdbeben von 2010 kamen viele
ausländer ins land und beim wiederaufbau
mitzuhelfen sie wollten souvenirs
mitnehmen
sogar ein paar touristen verschlug es
hierher
doch seit den protesten ist schluss paul
hat seit monaten nichts verkauft die
ausbildung musste er aufgeben
ich fühle mich als opfer der politiker
denn sie haben mir mal einzige
einnahmequelle glauben es ist als hätte
mich die politische situation mit einer
machete geschlagen
ich komme im leben nicht weiter aber
nicht weil meine produkte nicht kommt
ohne nicht schön sind sondern weil die
politische situation ausländer davon
abhält nach haiti zu kommen und bei mir
etwas zu kaufen
manchmal denke ich sollte idee einfach
verlassen
ein anderes land gehen denn hier gibt es
nichts für mich den anderen im
künstlerdorf geht es ähnlich für unsere
kameras machen sie sich ein bisschen an
die arbeit aber die stimmung ist
gedrückt was denken sie wie geht es
weiter
haiti hat eine zukunft wenn wir uns das
zum vorsatz machen wenn die
zusammenarbeiten uns zusammenschließen
dann können wir ja ideal für
veränderungen sollten dann kann es eine
bessere zukunft für haiti geben
robi blexer nur promi eigentlich haben
sie alle die gleiche botschaft
sie verstehen dass die haitianer
gemeinsam anpacken müssen wenn sich
etwas ändern soll
haiti war das erste land das sich aus
eigener kraft von der sklaverei befreit
mehr als 200 jahre später nehmen junge
haitianer ihr schicksal wieder in die
eigenen hände
im großen und im kleinen sie sind heidis
beste chance den teufelskreis aus armut
und instabilität zu durchbrechen